Hausa Gomez - pearpad you think you've
seen hardcore games flappy bird Dark
Souls I played them all but now we have
iron paints which we actually played
before but they added a new mode where
you flap by making a sound this is gonna
be terrible
okay so if I get 20 I can unlock the
banana man I [ __ ] need 20 right now
oh my god
okay hi really let's try that again
short sound equals 1 tab come on
am I sick oh oh come on I don't know
what sounds to make taking that out of
context oh it's too hard oh Sh
what are you s s baby
how the [ __ ] ah ah ah [ __ ] you ah zhabin
ya rabbi dick like a three-way
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you ass titties ass
ass ass too much ass god damn it s s s s
s s ass too much ass
God - Lane Dodge line Joyce Joyce said
dude Zeca dr. ja bitte bitte shut up
goddamn it you ruin it [ __ ] died
slide well I got four will Scott get out
and tell better okay this is so [ __ ]
hard oh shut up
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
I tried so hard
okay the beatbox shut you ruining what
the [ __ ] you doing that again and I'm
gonna castrate you actually it's already
castrated watch I spread all over my
screen huh is it weird to watch you
should probably watch this one with
headphones shut up ed gay baby thing man
why can't we just be to [ __ ] me yeah
yeah yeah
Oprah Oprah Oprah Oprah oh [ __ ] me Oprah
don't I hate this game no yes yes
well this Bend like the iPhone don't ask
me [ __ ] I said ass why not get it yes
and ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha oh that's
a good one
ah 10900 I don't think I think I can
doing that this is ridiculous
Oh pour pour pour pour pour pour pour
wha [ __ ] yo cupcake mania oh hi neck all
right that was iron pants I hope you
very much enjoyed this episode if you
didn't wear headphones it's gonna get
awkward once you leave that room it's
not like one of you enjoy watching bras
and hit the sky to come bro today ass
always lovely boys say awesome huh
you